we have the story from timcast.com Barry
Weiss criticizes musk for suspending
those reporting on private jet story
pundits respond Elon Musk himself
responded to her as Luke just mentioned
saying what would you do what is your
solution to real-time doxing the issue I
take with this as we get into the story
is journalists think they're above the
rules they think well someone already
published the private information
therefore it's okay for me to do it now
I was talking to a prominent leftist and
they were actually saying these
reporters were just reporting they
shouldn't have been banned and I said
but it's private information not public
information this person responded and
said it's already in the public I said
okay so if one of your enemies one of
your detractors post your address you
don't mind if we on our show will just
hold up your address because it's
already public information right of
course not of course they don't want
that it's sophistry they're coming up
with excuses so here's what happens
Barry White says the old regime at
Twitter governed by its own whims and
biases and it sure looks like the new
regime has the same problem I suppose uh
I said I oppose it in both cases and I
think those journalists who are
reporting on this uh reporting on a
story of public importance should be
reinstated
a lot of people criticize Barry Weiss
for this Elon Musk came out with a
legitimate question for her what is your
solution he then said it's not
rhetorical legit a bunch of leftists and
started mocking him saying he's His Own
Worst Enemy I actually think this shows
integrity the fact that Elon was willing
to give information to a journalist
who's not completely on board with him
shows he's going to be getting some you
know blowback from this because it's a
he's he's doing the right thing by
giving out the information but I don't
think Barry Weiss is completely wrong I
will say I think it's it was probably a
bit
um fast to give a seven day suspension
instantly without warning what should
have happened is he probably should have
deleted the tweets automatically and
then issued a warning where they lock
your account saying you cannot link to
this you have been warned we have
deleted the Tweet there definitely needs
to be some kind of procedure there
definitely needs to be some some strict
rules that people will understand and
follow and know if they break or don't
break but before the show began I posted
an image of a famous character
celebrating and being happy with the
caption journalists when people get
their account suspended and then that
same person being miserable and very
angry when journalists when other
journalists get their account suspended
so there's a lot of hypocrisy especially
when it comes to the corporate media
because essentially they didn't care
they didn't give a damn they celebrated
and cheered on the censorship of
everyone else but now that they deal
with it now all of all suddenly they
start to care about this issue here so
maybe some people are saying that this
could be 4D chess of Elon Musk trying to
get the corporate media to care about
censorship because they do now as of
course it's important to note here ABC
NBC CBS News all ignored the Twitter
files the Twitter files that expose the
government working with big Tech
censoring political speech that's one of
the biggest stories of our decade that
deserves a lot more coverage CNN only
covered it once so now
they kind of have to cover it and they
kind of do care about the censorship
finally I've heard a lot of people
saying like oh look at this Barry Weiss
is turning on Elon or whatever and I'm
like no I I actually agree with Barry to
a certain degree
that we are still I got a phone call
from a journalist they asked me they're
asking me about how Elon he responds to
certain accounts and this journalist is
like it's a journalist I know and
actually trust by the way I don't trust
a lot but someone who works for the post
and they were just like you know Elon
responds to people like Ian miles Chong
and you and I was like whoa me I was
like no you're mistaken like I think
he's tweeted at me like two or three
times in you know forever okay one of
them was about being Iron Man like not
not a legitimate thing these other
people he tweets it all the time like he
follows them really really closely he's
not following me and they were like oh
and I was like yeah uh I actually think
it's a problem this is what I told them
that we are once again just living under
the whims of a billionaire that being
said elon's done a whole lot of really
really good things so if we've gone from
corrupt crooked billionaires and
millionaires working with the FBI too
an emotional billionaire Who's acting on
his whims but outing and exposing
government corruption I will take it and
showing the hypocrisy of the corporate
media Keith olberman who was banned is
literally using his dog's account right
now in order to ban evade and he's
tweeting videos of him you might have
heard I got banned so he's so addicted
to the platform he he just can't get off
of it sorry I cut you up no no you're
fine I just was gonna say um you know I
find it uh fascinating that no actually
no lost it
Keith olberman's dogs here's here's the
here's the post he look Elon if you want
to rule with an iron fist there's one
thing you can do
people like this
just ban them just Ben Collins just ban
him okay Keith olberman band Griffin
band Kathy Griffin the reason is these
people are hyper emotional extremists
who post insane inflamed rhetoric
Ben Shapiro partisan conservative rather
tempered I think he put out a thread
where he was like I don't think these
journalists should have been banned
despite the fact that I don't like them
rupar is a bad journalist but if they're
reporting like he's got his opinions
he's got strong opinions but he's not
going on Twitter and screaming at the
top of his lungs and shaking his face
like Keith Olbermann does all were men
calls for like military rendition of
people it's just psychotic rhetoric but
it works you know who I'm I'm sorry
there's a there's a there's a follow
I recommend and you two guys the
krasenstein brothers
do you guys remember the Crescent scenes
are they wait are they back they're
better they're back oh and they're great
and they're great so uh I actually had
that I'm blocked and muted they come
back and I unblock and unmute them
because I guess they reach out to
someone and said hey Tim's got his block
and blocked him and they posted some
funny jokes
they're actually having sane rational
conversations about what's going on they
they uh um I think Brian posted
something about you know if the
reporters are publishing public
information it shouldn't be you know
banned I responded with it wasn't public
it was private and Aaron rupar one of
the journals who got banned admitted to
linking to it and the response was
interesting points can you provide more
information and evidence I sent it to
him and he says very interesting I still
think there should be a procedure for
this that people understand I said you
are correct wow that's fantastic that is
a guy who hates Donald Trump who has
called him out and annoyed a lot of
people but actually having a real
conversation and saying okay I disagree
with you on that one but that that is
correct I I gotta agree and I'm like
that's the kind of rhetoric you want
Keith olberman is the opposite he
bannivates he's got look he's unkempt
he's he's ranting I mean let me play
some of this for you for not doing
something he claimed he would never
Donnie O'Sullivan Ryan Mack it's the
baptism scene from The Godfather movie
and we all got whacked by Don Elon
musklione for a moment last night I
thought you know he did this just so
we'd all forget about Donald Trump's
stupid baseball cards from yesterday let
me talk about that too plus thurber's
the cat bird seed this guy desperately
needs to be Cut Off from Twitter I'm
sorry he's just like reading off this
terrible stand-up routine that he's been
rehearsing he's reading tweets on paper
he's got other people said dude you need
to go touch grass every time I watch one
of his videos I think to myself doesn't
anyone in his life love him enough to
get him the help that he needs
apparently not he must just be that kind
of a person I can't help but bringing
Donald Trump into these everything every
this is an Elon Musk story exclusively
oh but let me talk about Trump and his
nfts like hey I'm not a fan of the nfts
but come on man I love people will tweet
at me like touch grass Tim and it's like
dude I go skating almost every day I
ride I've got an electric motorbike that
I ride around I'm in big fields and
there are trees and there are deer
there's too many deer guys like no is it
a year ago there was like three now
there's like 15 on my lawn every night
I'm getting worried but I'm I'm out here
you know getting away from the city
I'm on Twitter
posting jokes and ish posts and nonsense
because I I just think it's all silly
these people live on Twitter and are
frantic and ranting and calling for I
think it was Oberman who called for a
military rendition of Donald Trump and
it's like dude
like Elon he said some time away from
Twitter would do him good
yes okay just IP ban him and just give
him a week a week for him to go outside
and just stare at a rock or a tree and
then come down talk to your neighbors
man yeah I mean I'm pretty sure he lives
in New York City and I'm pretty sure he
might be like
um like what's his name Howard Stern and
uh kind of afraid of
the flu going around I want to go back
to it came back to me the point that you
were making about Elon um and it's like
okay we're making a little bit of
progress right baby steps but I also
think it is important and I'm sure you
guys have have talked about this but I
think it's very important for people to
remember because there are a lot of
people on the right who they're like the
the nerdy kid at the dance they're like
oh my God someone finally likes us
please yes invite me to the dance and
it's like he's not I would not say he's
with you on all things we'll take the
win when we can get it right but like
he's a transhumanist he's a big you know
uh climate change guy like let's
progress is progress let's take baby
steps we'll take the wins where we can
but like don't get too trusting in just
this one guy like he's going to be your
savior I think Elon will ultimately
strip Twitter to its Bare Bones and a
lot of the things that are being talked
about with rev share and stuff probably
won't happen very very loose prediction
right here I don't I don't know if it's
likely or not I'm just saying here's
what I see we got a report that he's
seeking new investment
for for Twitter so he they just opened
up at a at a 44 billion dollar
evaluation offering for investors to
come in because he wants to offload that
debt he has that debt is going to bring
I think a billion dollars per year in
interest he's got to get that down Elon
even tweeted don't hold debt in a you
know environment like this then he sold
more Tesla shares I think he sold was
like three billion or three point
something billion clearly he's trying to
get that debt down but Twitter probably
is not as expensive as people think it
is to operate it is a very rudimentary
service when you think about it it's
hosting text granted videos and photos
if you go back to the early days of
Twitter when you wanted to post a photo
or video you had to use a separate third
party service this is like 10 years ago
and so if you went on Twitter and posted
an image it would then go to a different
company that would automatically post it
was like you you'd approve an app or
something like that but Twitter was just
text they they expanded they added all
these features it became very expensive
what I think is going to happen is
elon's got a secure investment and pay
down his debt he will probably be able
to be able to pay down the debt but then
he's got to get costs way down they're
not getting enough Twitter blue users so
what I think will ultimately happen it
will probably just maybe from where we
are right now there's a million and one
variables standing before us I think
Twitter could eventually become a
decentralized fetiverse Style app which
will just be a massive Community he sold
uh 3.6 billion dollars worth of a Tesla
stock just recently and it's going to be
interesting because I don't see him kind
of doing that I see them I see him kind
of moving forward with the X app the app
of everything the WeChat of China here
in the United States uh but he it's
important to know here he fired what was
it nearly half of it hey staff eighty
percent eighty percent of the staff at
Twitter and the app's working better
than ever I know like he's like
Twitter's amazing right now everyone
wants to be on the app including Keith
olberman who's on his dogs including
Kathy Griffin that's on her Dead Mothers
this is the play used to be where you
have the conversations of of literally
yay saying Shalom so so when you have
such craziness unfolding on this app
there's a lot of High Hopes I think he
has a lot of high hopes to make it the
app of everything the next WeChat I
think that's that's pretty clear here
but it's the debt financing that has me
thinking it may turn into something a
bit different maybe it does become the X
app but it won't be this
hyper-centralized monolith it'll be some
kind of decentralized app that has these
these plugins in it for doing certain
things like Payment Processing but the
the debt's massive and the fact that you
know he said what in April he's not
going to sell anymore or something like
that then he sold 3.6 billion
yeah you know he's he's got to find the
cash he's got to get rid of that 13
billion dollars in debt apparently some
big investors are interested and I do
hope they get involved but the media
attack is Relentless all of the
reporting is like why would anyone
invest in a company that's burning
advertisers and bleeding money and it's
just like it's it's mostly not true but
they're trying to destroy Twitter it's
funny as soon as they lost control they
tried setting fire to it yeah ain't that
the truth yeah if they can't have the
narrative nobody can so in the end if
Elon can't pull it off
decentralized Federated social media app
and I think that may be better
you know I think back to web 1.0 and it
was so much better back then but it was
probably better because the only people
who used it were
I don't know how to describe it driven
individuals individuals in the know when
the internet was dominated only by those
who sought out to use the internet and
not by people who had to use the
internet it was wild it was free it was
fun there were weird websites there were
gifs of Macho Man you know dancing and
there was crazy music and then once the
internet became a utility for the
average person everything homogenized
and solidified into basic programs you
got your news you got your your game app
you've got your banking app and
everything is apps everything's placed
into a little box no more Wild West no
more fun a lot of people have talked
about how can we get back to those days
well Elon Musk has has lit that fire a
little bit bringing back free speech to
a certain degree and then you know
kicking out the narrative but uh I don't
know if we'll get back to that point
potentially through you know Federated
networks and things like that as an
aside too I guess we move on apparently
I don't know if this is true look if you
heard this that Twitter's banned linking
to passed it on directly now
um I'm not I can't clarify that I I
haven't seen that myself personally I
don't believe them yeah like these
leftists are like you can't even link to
Mastodon now I'm like yeah you're lying
about something I do you guys ever get
depressed thinking about the fact that
you know Elon has made some changes to
Twitter and that's great but
imagine what's lurking over at Facebook
and YouTube and you know all these other
places where are we ever gonna get to
the bottom of that no
I always think about what did they do
like the people that were running
Twitter before weren't dumb they left a
bunch of evidence but I'm sure they
scrambled to delete a lot yeah this is
just what we found this is only what we
found so I can only imagine what yeah it
had a year to do it yeah that would that
that sucks and this could be why these
latest documents are coming from uh you
know things that happened under Elon
right yeah because all the other stuff
could be still kept uh hidden in secret
so uh I mean if Elon said this is the
coup de gras
I mean you know seeing the FBI make
direct requests for takedowns is huge
was that it come on yeah I don't have a
lot of Hope in Congress but there are
going to be some hearings from this
there should be huge National Senate and
Correctional hearings into all of this
and we should get everything that's
happening behind the scenes uh there
there should be a total disclosure
because if the same FBI agents are going
to Twitter they're probably also going
to YouTube they're probably also going
to Facebook so if they are subpoenaed if
the files aren't destroyed or deleted or
covered up which they probably are
there's going to be links to other
channels there's going to be a bigger
kind of onion unraveling here so
um
yes it is it is it is and this is what
we know this is what's on Twitter side
imagine what's on the government It's
gotta get really depressed that's really
dark for me to think about like God this
is disgusting and this is just
scratching the surface wait until you
find out about the island that they go
to
unless you make it all public all of the
accounts are what was the term
de-amplified have no way of knowing that
they were targeted and without that
evidence you know no not that I think
they get a fair day in court but they
are completely reliant on big Tech and
Congress working it out they have no
chance to advocate for themselves they
need to be able to say hey look here's
the communication here's the list that
Twitter and the FBI put me on saying
that my content should be limited I mean
if we don't make this public to the
people who were affected themselves
we're just stuck in the same Wormhole
right we're dependent on bigger
representation to take care of these
things which it's it's almost impossible
to ask them for especially if you're
thinking about seeking monetary damages
or anything else right yeah and I know
that Elon said that he was going to have
some sort of a way for people to find
out if they were being suppressed
somehow but I don't think that he
clarified whether he meant whether they
were suppressed currently like in that
moment or go back in history and look to
see if they had been suppressed at any
moment in time right I would love to for
him to clarify on that I mean I know
he's got a lot of stuff going on but I I
think this is something that should be
given priority I mean I appreciate that
this is something you know that he wants
to roll out systematically and there's a
timeline he wants to establish but I bet
there are a lot of people who if given
access to a database of this information
know they could find themselves on one
of these lists and who would be willing
or have the support to do something
about it
we'll kiss that uh Government funding
for SpaceX goodbye I mean with all the
people he's upsetting oh yeah you know
can we can we give a shout out to uh
Mike Lindell who's back on Twitter to
Jim Hoff to get away pundit who's back
on Twitter and of course James O'Keefe
who is back on Twitter uh you know him
you'll love him I'm I'm glad to see that
uh Elon Musk is Banning the fake news
and restoring the real news and Robert
Malone and Peter McCullough espresso
back on the platform I um today it's not
good days I think that it's you know
you're talking about banning people for
satire and comedy and stuff and how that
was wrong and I don't disagree with you
but I do think it's important to take a
step back and say like well it's not
just that right like people still should
be allowed to post something that's just
completely inaccurate as well it doesn't
have to be that it's satire or comedy or
anything else
um but uh yeah it's it's nice to see
especially James O'Keefe man he's been
doing such great work yeah lately
absolutely I am going to uh I'm gonna
pull up a story real quick while you
guys I'm gonna say that Keith Oberman uh
reminds me you know how like they say
the people who are addicted to the
social media are like teens like
especially teen girls and you take their
phone away and they freak out like I
feel like that's actually Keith like
he's more important
right he's so addicted to the likes and
reactions on Twitter that he is like
going on to his dog's account he can't
be away from him I actually like not
really know that much about him before
this and such a weird impression thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time